The design study itself is presented in a report. It may include charts, tables,
graphs and screenshots, as well as, as well as descriptive text. It is,
however, not a narrative, but a dish, dispassionate description of a systematic
exploration. I want your reports to be professional in quality. This means that
you should treat it like you would if you were preparing to show it to customers
or submit it for publications. Its spelling and grammar should be checked, and
it should be carefully proofread by a team member other than its author.
We will now go through each of the sections of the report, indicating what
is expected in that section. This should also give you an idea of what you
need to do during the study itself to gather the data that goes into the report.